they say that it is very difficult to learn Russian
I already spoke many languages
when I decided to study it and wanted to
study a more difficult language it was a
wonderful decision that literally
turned my life upside down
if you have doubts about the
Russian language and about learning
Russian in general I will tell you  the
next study of it will give you huge
benefits, not only can you
communicate with millions of people, but also the
structure of your brain changes and
improves as you have to
think differently using new and unusual
language structures
now let me tell you about how I
learned my
first lesson in Russian  which I learned is
that especially in the case of languages
that have non-Latin spelling,
it is very very important to know how to
start
Cyrillic correctly, in general it is not difficult,
you can learn it in a few days,
but problems arise when you need to
type on the keyboard and the fact is that the
Russian keyboard  has
another tray so you need to pr  and
get used to a completely different
typing system it's like learning to play the
piano from the beginning but with other
notes i downloaded a
phonetic keyboard and so the keyboard is
very easy and intuitive to use
when i started using it typing in
russian became easier and faster
in russian  there are cases
Russian-speaking people take it for a
must but they don't learn cases
from grammar tables they learn those who
actively use languages ​​speak
it and breaking there a natural pint and a
polyglot reminded us of this and this is
very, very important to remember when learning
languages ​​​​from service and grammatical
structures  like a language you would not learn
first start listening and reading and only
then
turn to grammar books and everything
will fall into place as I said at the
beginning of this video learning Russian
will give you huge benefits it
became obvious when I visited Russia
for the first time  once at first glance it may
seem that Russian people are a little
cold  but if you speak
their language, they will immediately become welcome,
but let's go back in time, I have always
been fascinated by the
history of the Second World War from the very
beginning, I dreamed of personally talking with those
who survived this difficult period for the
Russian people, although unfortunately I could
not personally  to meet such a person
but thanks to Russian I was able to read
books and articles,
it helped me a lot to understand this
topic from the point of view of Russian people
Russian expanded my understanding of
space and time and
language I am proud to be able to tell
you all this in Russian
thank you very much  you listened to me and
if you want to know more click on the
link in the description i wrote an article in
english and russian on my blog see you
soon and bye bye
[music]